apple does not sell Nike does not sell
most of their product through Google
AdWords or affiliate marketing they sell
most of their products because they
built brand a lot of people here are
incredibly focused on selling so they
like Google AdWords because it converts
better lower funnel conversion based
marketing right the reality is that's
great selling's important that's how a
business Grooms but when you are
building brand when people care about
you or your business that is the
ultimate form of selling there is no
affiliate there's no portal there's no
Google ads that are more powerful than
building a brand Brazil what's good
[Applause]
you know I gave a lot of thought on the
long flight from New York to the show on
what did I want to talk about what what
would bring the most value to the
audience here with the makeup of what I
knew about who's here and obviously a
lot of people are here on different
parts of their journey in building their
brand their business their happiness and
what really came to mind for me as I
started to go through it in my head was
there was two places and that is really
attention and accountability that the
two places that I could talk about today
that would bring the most value was to
focus on those two things the concept of
where is the attention of all the places
that everyone here wants to reach and
then how accountable
is everyone here to themselves and even
more importantly to the team or the
people that they're building with so
that's where I'm going to go on this the
reason I like to focus on attention so
much is when I think about my career
actually this is a good question how
many people here are familiar with me
and my content raise your hand
thank you
now I'm going to ask who's not familiar
don't worry you will not hurt my
feelings I just want to get a sense
because I want to know where I want to
go how many people here are not familiar
with me and don't know my content raise
your hands
okay that hurts I paid attention I don't
like you I just
first of all I'm extremely humbled by
how many are for the ones that aren't
but even for the ones that are I'm going
to start here because it really is going
to matter for where I think all of you
are going over the next 10 years even
when I was six years old and wanted to
sell lemonade
when I was a child in New Jersey the
thing that I spent most of my time on
was not making the lemonade though it
had to be good enough to drink
not standing behind the desk
or the table that I had for my lemonade
I spent most of my time walking up and
down the streets of New Jersey and
trying to watch Cars drive by
and try to figure out which tree or what
street sign to put my lemonade stand
sign on that gave me a better chance to
sell lemonade I didn't understand what I
was doing at six years old when I was 11
years old I sold trading cards and
collectible stickers at shows
I spent so much time thinking about how
I would build out my table and where I
would put what cards and what stickers
and I would walk the whole show and pay
attention to how people set up their
tables
what I was doing at that age and then
when I turned 14 and 15 and started
working for my dad's liquor store
I would watch customers walk through the
front door of the liquor store and I
would pay attention to how they would
walk where they would go what displays
they looked at what shelves they looked
at and what I was doing my whole life
and what I do for a living now and what
every single person at this conference
whether you work for a big brand or
you're an entrepreneur whether you've
been doing it for five years or today is
the first day you're going on this
journey what I was doing then and what
everyone needs to be doing now is
following the attention
too many people here get comfortable
with one or two platforms to make
content
or one or two ways of how they sell
product and they become in love with it
and they become complacent and they stop
evolving to where the attention is my
career as a content creator started on
YouTube in 2006
but it was Twitter in 2007 and it was
Instagram in 2011 and it was all these
other platforms along the way snap and
Tick Tock and Linkedin and YouTube
shorts and Facebook and even ones that
didn't last forever how many people here
by show of hands remember Vine the app
remember that
that didn't last forever
but in the two years that it was
dominating or the year and a half a lot
of attention was grown from that
platform more importantly
a lot of people learned by doing Vine
how to make short videos which is now
one of the most important ways to
communicate in our society
the biggest thing that I'm trying to
leave this conference with is getting
everyone here dramatically more
accountable
to focus on attention not where you want
to make content but where your customer
is
you may not like Tick Tock or YouTube or
Facebook or Instagram or Twitter but if
your customer's attention is there
you not liking it is only achieving one
thing you losing out on more customers
this is an incredibly important
framework and it's a very big issue in
today's world because most people are
not producing enough content to enough
places a lot of people here
are incredibly focused on selling so
they like Google AdWords because it
converts better lower funnel conversion
based marketing right the reality is
that's great selling's important that's
how a business grooms but when you were
building brand
when people care about you or your
business that is the ultimate form of
selling there is no affiliate there's no
portal there's no no Google ads that are
more powerful than building a brand
apple does not sell Nike does not sell
most of their product
through Google AdWords or affiliate
marketing
they sell most of their products because
they've built brand the number one goal
from every single person here and every
business here is to build a brand
when you build brand you don't have to
sell it comes to you
how do you build brand is what I'm
passionate about and where do you build
brand is what I'm passionate about and
that's why I start this talk and I'm
focused on attention and accountability
most people in this room have not been
accountable
to executing against your big words I've
been flying the last day and yesterday
this conference went on and today when I
land and I searched Twitter X and all
the other platforms and I see a lot of
people here commenting about what
they're doing at this conference and
what they're up to and of course I have
to hit the translation because it's in
Portuguese and I want to know what you
said
and when I read it a lot of people here
are talking big game
a lot of you are talking about building
huge companies and you're going to be
massive and you're going to build big
stuff and then when I click on that
account and try to find what they're
doing on the internet they're producing
very little content
we must be accountable that if we're
talking big game that our actions have
to match our mouth
thank you
what do I mean by that I mean
I'm 47. I started marketing when I was
15. really actively for my father's
business that means I've been marketing
for over 30 years 30 years ago how many
people here are under 35 years old raise
your hands
first of all let's clap it up for all
these young [__]
so kids that are under 35 let me tell
you a story
when I was a young man marketing for my
dad's liquor store and wine store if you
wanted to get people to know about you
you had to pay
I had to pay a newspaper to put an
advertising in the newspaper I had to
pay
a cable company to run my TV commercial
I had to pay
for a billboard to show my sign I had to
pay
the marketing Direct Mail company to
make a flyer and send it into your
mailbox so you would see it I had to pay
today
the attention of the world
lives
in here
the things that dominate here is gaming
and entertainment and social networks
people here complain that they're not
getting a lot of views on their videos
on Instagram or Tick Tock or these
platforms but they have forgotten that
it's free
[Music]
let me say this nice and slow today
if you were to advertise on social
networks the cost of showing up
not making it but showing up
is free
this is crazy Google which I used a lot
Google AdWords how many people here do
Google AdWords pretty aggressively from
your business
a little higher I just want to get a
sense
a lot of you
Google charges you money when somebody
clicks
not everybody converts you try to figure
out if the amount you pay do enough
people convert that it's worth your
money but it still costs you money
The Social Network Revolution is insane
it is free
to build brand
most people in this room most people in
Brazil most people in South America most
people in the world
do not produce enough content for how
big the opportunity is for free
attention
that is the biggest elephant in this
room today
it is a wow
it's a wow because it's [__] free
and yet people will complain and say oh
Instagram Shadow Banned Me Nobody Shadow
band meet you you just suck at social
media
and so I come here on this long flight
to pound here for the next 45 minutes
attention
attention will get you everything you
want you want to sell a course attention
you want to sell a t-shirt attention you
want to be the mayor of this town
attention you want to raise some money
for your non-profit because you're
passionate about it attention you want
to be an actor attention attention it is
the only asset that everyone in here
must Chase to produce what they want
being unemotional about where the
attention is is very important
too many of you have demonized platforms
out of
your subjective opinion
a bad experience
and we must get over that hump once you
get over the hump once you sit in this
room and understand that everything you
want to happen is about building brand
and sales in social networks
then you start having to get good at it
right it's like health and fitness I can
tell you the way to get healthier is to
eat better and go to the gym and once
you understand that that there's no
magic pill then you can do it the
problem is there's a good way to work
out and there's a bad way there's a good
way to eat clean and healthy and there's
an okay way where you get tricked if
it's really healthy or not
the thing I spend all my time on today
in my career
even though I've been in this for a long
time on the flight here with Dustin with
raghav all I was talking about was the
strategies on the creative that we're
posting in Social is the thumbnail good
how many people here are familiar with
Mr Beast the YouTuber raise your hands
Mr Beast reportedly spends a hundred
fifty thousand dollars per thumbnail on
his YouTube videos
let me say that nice and slow one more
time for everybody
Mr Beast spends a hundred fifty thousand
dollars in testing and production for
every thumbnail of the videos he puts up
on YouTube now obviously he makes an
incredible amount of money from his
YouTube videos but understand the it's
not about how much I need everybody here
to understand the commitment
most people hear when they post on
social media post because they're
following a trend that they think will
do well or some [__] they want to say
but they give no thought and this is the
most important line maybe of the entire
talk so I want everyone to pay attention
they give no thought to the science
of the art
no thought of the math around the art to
build the brand I know there's a lot of
people here who do conversion and lower
funnel and affiliate and Google AdWords
I I love that world I lived in it in the
you know late 90s early 2000s I just
want that audience which is a big part
of this percentage to hear why I'm
focusing so heavily on social it's
because of attention one more time how
many people here are very aggressively
doing Google AdWords and before you
raise your hand Google AdWords is a big
part of your revenue for your business
please raise your hand raise it
so for the appreciate it for the 100
people that just raised their hand
their Reliance on Google AdWords is
something they have to think about every
day because I don't think I have to tell
anyone here what's happening more and
more people are using Ai and chat CBT to
do search than Google if the attention
goes away from Google to search
well you're not going to be able to
convert as easily if you're getting your
business from referrals and Affiliates
let me promise you they're getting their
traffic from Google if AI wins the next
three to five years and most of us are
going to chat GPT or something like it
instead of Google it's just what Google
did to the Yellow Pages and all the
directories of before all the money used
to be made by people that would open the
Yellow Pages or the directories and they
would call a business that went to
Google that went out of business Google
is not the end state
Google is not the last way it's going to
be we are all sitting here today and all
very aware how many people here have
played with an AI bot have used or tried
chat GPT raise your hand
actually stand up if you've used an AI
bot like stand up I want everybody to
visualize this is very important if
you've used chat GPT or something like
it to search something or get
information please stand up and don't be
lazy this is very important to everybody
I don't care how tired you are get the
[__] up if you've used chat CPT
I love you back now listen
before you sit down because some of you
are lazy look around
look around
look around this is just starting
this is just starting you can sit
thank you for doing that for me because
here's what's important
do you know what I am scared about every
day when I love people in business
that they become too high on their own
Supply
meaning they become complacent to what's
working today without realizing that the
thing that's making their living and
their business is in danger
even if you lose 30 percent of the
attention on search to chat GPT or
something like it that is going to raise
your cost of clicks and acquisition
dramatically enough to maybe not make it
viable to what you sell it doesn't have
to go to zero for it to be a problem for
you as a matter of fact as people start
changing their behavior and 20 or 30
percent less go to Google to look as
that number goes down the people you're
competing with to be the first result in
a Google ad are going to start paying
more because they're going to start
getting nervous and it's going to drive
your cost up to compete this is very
important I see a lot of smart people
shaking their heads right now listen to
me my friends
six years how many people here have been
following my content for more than five
years raise your hand
for the people that just raised their
hand you all remember five years ago
when I was yelling tick tock tick tock
tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock
and all of you thought it was little
girls dancing
I thought it's where the world's
attention was about to go many of you
who just raised their hands did not take
advantage of going hard on Tick Tock
when I told you
and you left money on the table it
doesn't mean that your business isn't
good it doesn't mean that things aren't
fine it just means that you could have
been twice as big
you know when people are like Gary you
keep talking about doing this and that
but my business is doing six million I'm
like what's wrong with 12 million
and more importantly when you're
complacent and you become lazy and you
become one-dimensional on one or two
things that work almost always six
million becomes 3 not 12. my friends I
come to Brazil today in the late summer
of 2023 to tell you a very distinct
message I've been following attention on
the internet for 20 years religiously
we are in a moment right now where
there's more change coming in the next
24 months than I've seen in a long time
since really 2005-6-7 when Myspace and
Facebook and Twitter and I was like okay
this is different this is not blogging
this is different this is not dig and
Reddit this is different and obviously
social networks took us to adultly
different place we sit here today with
AI looming you just saw how many people
stood up we sit here today
with the platforms becoming more
complicated and the content requiring
you to be better at it how many people
here feel like they're fairly active and
are serious about doing business on
Instagram raise your hands I just want
to say raise your hands high
for all the people that just raised
their hands do we not all agree and you
can just head nod do we not all agree
that over the last 12 months six months
that the organic reach on Instagram has
down down quite a bit right I see it
right it's gone down because all that is
happening is supply and demand very
simple Concept in business supply and
demand
yesterday more content was produced on
Instagram than any other day in the
history of life
however in the last four years an
enormous amount of the attention has
gone to tick tock
so if more content was made yesterday
than ever before
but in the last three to four years an
extraordinary amount of attention hours
has gone to tick tock and YouTube shorts
and other places what do you think is
going to happen with your organic reach
more ads have been spent on Instagram
yesterday than ever before what do you
think is going to happen to your organic
reach
this is all supply and demand of
attention
but like I started this talk this is
also time for all of you to become
accountable
today's Champion is tomorrow's loser
there are a lot of people sitting here
feeling good about themselves based on
2015 marketing Behavior
and they don't realize that the shift is
coming and the two or three things that
they do well
are starting to change right in front of
their eyes and instead of being
accountable and putting in more work to
learn they're putting their head in the
sand and saying [__] AI I don't care
about Tick Tock I don't need this I've
got this figured out
good news for me I respect that you have
to live your life if you decide to lose
20 to 50 percent of your business's
revenue or your growth that's on you
you're not my brother
you're not my mother
I actually don't give a [__] if you
listen to any of my advice
on the flip side
the last 20 years of my career has been
very very very enjoyable
I know that in two years I will be on a
flight to Dubai I'll catch up on all my
work and five of you in this audience
will email me and say I was at your talk
in August of 23 in Brazil and I was
strictly doing affiliate lower funnel
and you convinced me to get serious
about building brand and social and
focusing on what's going on in Ai and I
just want to thank you because you were
right I was slowly declining a little
bit or I was flat in 22 and 23 and since
there my business has doubled that is an
email that I am lucky enough to get
almost daily over the last 10 years that
is my intent to be here and that is what
I wish on all of you
how many people here have more than
three employees raise your hand more
than three raise your hands okay I'll go
there then I'm going to talk on this for
a few minutes given how many people
raised their hands
accountability
when you have employees
the number one thing that I focus on and
I think about for the people in here
that want to grow
is the inability to understand the
biggest truth of when you own a business
which is if you have employees you work
for them they don't work for you
this is a big deal
most people
it's just natural it's the way we think
I know how the world works most people
think I'm paying you
[__] do [__] for me makes sense
and it's not wrong it's actually very
logical and I understand I also have a
belief in that to some degree however
back to my purpose
with this talk today
to everyone here
if you have the emotional strength to
understand it's the reverse I promise
you you've started down the path of
actually growing your business
growing up in my father's business I saw
how my dad thought about his
relationship with his employees the
first time I went to the store to work
he told me to keep an eye on them
because he thought some of them were
trying to steal
it was an old school mentality that he
learned growing up in Russia where I was
born
today a lot of us business owners are
worried about the reverse we're worried
about our employees being too entitled
not wanting to do stuff wanting to get
paid to do little I understand covid
created new variables there are people
that don't even want to go into an
office literally asking someone to go to
an office five days a week now seems
like you're crazy
the world changes I get that but
following and finding your balance
on being a leader to your people
will get so much more value out of them
you would be shocked vaynermedia is now
2 000 people globally vaynerx
because we have six or seven companies
every time I hire someone new that's
senior and they come into the company
they are shocked by how long
a lot of the employees have been in the
company the company's only 14 years old
we have dozens and dozens and dozens of
people that have been there for 9 10 11
years
for people here in marketing they know
advertising agencies people last two
years maybe three
the reason is because I live what I
believe in but there's a business Reason
Not only does it feel well
not doesn't feel good to do right by
your people it's good for your business
when people stay in a company for a long
time they have institutional knowledge
Sports
I know this country loves its Sports
sports do you know what one of the
biggest variables in sports besides
having competition in your soul is speed
speed matters
speed matters in sports and speed
matters in business so much
how many people here that have three or
four or more employees the number one
hidden problem they have is they're in
too many meetings
the number one poison for their company
is meetings are too long and there's too
many of them
when you have people that stay with you
a long time meetings can be 15 minutes
instead of one hour because everyone's
talking the same [__] language
I have meetings with people on the way
to the bathroom and not even talking to
them
when you work with somebody for 10 years
I could leave my desk go to the bathroom
look them in the face head nod and we
both know exactly what the [__] we need
to do next
that is how you scale that is how you
build a bigger business I implore
everyone here implore everybody here to
get dramatically more serious of
building a positive culture in this
business now that doesn't mean coddle
your people I'm not saying for you to
create entitlement and let everyone be
lazy I'm saying be a human being and
care about your employees talk to them
understand because when you have
employees employees care about different
things I have employees who want more
money makes sense
I have employees who don't necessarily
want more money they want more vacation
time because they just had a child makes
sense I have some employees who you know
in my mind are a little bit insecure and
so for them it's not the money it's not
the vacation time they just want a more
senior title on their LinkedIn and their
resume as a boss as a leader it is not
your judge to judge what your employees
want it's your job to understand what
your employees want and try to make it
happen
Brazil understood
good
attention
attention can be very overpriced and it
could be very underpriced and there is
no general rule how many people here do
for their company have done marketing
with influencers or creators you've paid
an influencer or Creator to bring
awareness to your business raise your
hands raise them hi please
okay for the hundred or so that have
raised their hands influencers
in general
remarkably possible for it to be
underpriced you can pay an influencer a
couple hundred bucks a couple thousand
bucks ten thousand bucks and get
enormous return on your investment on
the flip side
how many people here have paid
influencers and it was a [__] show did
not do anything raise your hands
how many people here have done things
with influencers and it was a very good
thing and was good for your business
raise your hands
almost everyone who raised their hand
for the first thing raised their hand
for the second thing this is why I want
to talk about attention per behavior in
the world we live in today many of you
may ask is influencer marketing good the
answer is Maybe
it can be good it can be bad
that is actually the same for everything
if you think about it a football
is that good for your business
for Messi it was very good
for Ronaldo it was very good
they made billions of dollars the ROI of
a football for those human beings was a
lot for me I played two weekends ago and
I hurt my hamstring
that was negative Roi
that is the same for everything we're
going to talk about to close this out
the following Platforms in Brazil have
huge opportunities for business growth
but you may do well with it or you may
not do well with it it is based on your
skill on how you pick the influencers
what you're looking for the influencers
to do the direction you've given the
influencers to do what you want to do
and the same is true for the content you
make on YouTube on Facebook on Instagram
on Snapchat on Pinterest every one of
the top 10 Platforms in the world are an
incredible opportunity for many people
here
the problem is if you think back to the
other things you've done email marketing
affiliate Google AdWords
it didn't do well at first either
potentially because you didn't know what
you were doing
the key here is to leave this conference
understanding that you have to put it in
the work
put in the work to actually be good at
the craft
let me give you some things to think
about tactically to be good at the craft
how many people here post every day on
social media raise your hands every day
on social media raise your hands higher
please
how many people here do not post on
social media at all raise your hands
John
Paulo get up here you can get up here
get up here
let's clap it up for this pioneer
this is a very amazing man in 2023 he
does not post in social media at all we
must clap for him louder
how are you very fine you could speak in
Portuguese tell them in Portuguese why
you do not post
Ed
I'm very lazy lazy
is that true you believe that I don't
give a [__] you don't give a [__] no
to me anyone who has hit the highest
level of happiness
to me the highest level of happiness is
I don't give a [__]
as much as I want to tell him what's
good about this and what's good about
that this wonderful bearded man had has
achieved the highest level of humanity
we must give him a standing ovation he
doesn't give a [__] stand up and clap up
[Applause]
I almost feel like my talk should be
done now
for the rest of you
who have not achieved the final stage of
humanity
and still give some [__]
it's re I'm really really passionate
about a couple things one is
self-awareness
I didn't know where that gentleman was
going to go with his answer he went to
the my favorite place but
one of the things I recognize today is
when I sit here and say to all of you
regardless of what you do B2B SAS small
company big company Creator entrepreneur
real estate selling course I don't know
what you do what I do know is that it's
inconceivable whether LinkedIn or
YouTube Shorts Facebook or Instagram
that those platforms that are free
are not the best use of your time to get
good at and put a lot of effort towards
including hiring people and spending
money on it because it's free to
distribute it it's not free to make it
unless you do it yourself and your time
is not free right
as I sit here and not knowing what that
gentleman was going to say I do think
there's a starting point to the journey
that I want to push all of you to make
more of which is self-awareness
not everybody in this Hall in this
conference should be making videos on
the internet
they're not good at it and that's okay
you can practice and get better but
maybe it's just not for you and that's
okay I think the biggest problem today
is that most people feel to be good at
social media you have to be on camera
and that is crazy you have a business
when you have a business you do not have
to be on camera it's a good thing to be
on camera if you like it or you're good
at it you should be on camera but if you
are not good at it and you do not like
it
and you genuinely understand yourself I
know no matter how much I practice
singing I will only be so good I will be
better in a year if I practice singing
every day then I would sing tonight
but I'll still be at a very low level I
can never be Beyonce
I can practice football like I did two
centers ago but I promise you there is
no World Cup in my future
other things
I was able to maximize all that practice
as a child selling lemonades and
baseball cards and wine led me to being
a very successful entrepreneur that is
true for everyone here
you need to figure out if you are not
doing this because you don't want to and
you're not good at it or because of the
thing that scares me the most in this
room today
that the reason most of you
aren't doing what I'm talking about even
though you didn't need me here to fly 12
hours to tell you to do it is because
you're scared of other people's opinions
when they leave comments on what you
post
the biggest thing I fear is that you are
not living your happiest life or your
most successful business because you are
worried about the opinion of someone who
is anonymous
on the internet
I'm just going to give you one tidbit on
this
if a human being
lives the life where they spend their
time
going around social networks finding
your content and leaving something nasty
about you that you are not good looking
that you are stupid that you don't know
what you're talking about do not feel
bad for yourself
feel bad for them
do you know how sad of a life it is to
take your time to seek out people on the
internet that you don't know and leave
nasty comments to make them feel bad
that person is in a very bad place
when I say feel bad for them I don't
mean say [__] you and be mad at them I'm
saying have compassion and sympathy for
them that they are in a bad place in
their lives that they are spending their
valuable time to try to hurt your
feelings someone they probably don't
even know
if we can get the world to have more
compassion
for the people that are nasty
the world could be in a much better
place
and more importantly thank you and more
importantly that's a big goal
you'll be happier if you can find
compassion and empathy for people that
are dragging you down do not let your
self-esteem be wrapped up in the fact
that you only got 25 views on a video I
only got 25 views on my first video too
and my second and my fourth and my ninth
nobody was watching my [__] [__] but
I knew that the video on the internet
thing in 2006 was gonna happen and I put
in the work
all the best stuff is happening when
you're putting in the work
not the results
so please be self-aware of who you are
are you insecure or are you self-aware
and realize video is not your format but
maybe the written word is
you put a picture let me give you a good
example the number one mistake that
almost everyone here is making on
Instagram is they're mailing it in when
they do the copy on their post
they're not writing enough or
thoughtfully enough on the caption on
their post they do the video in the
picture they think that's what it is and
on the written word they just say huh
say something funny something clever
three words and they're done post
if everybody here started writing three
or four sentences
in detail that brought value
to the video that they're posting they
would see enormous growth from their
Baseline overnight
maybe for you you're not good on video
but you can take a picture of your
product or your service or your industry
and then write three paragraphs on your
Instagram post and that's how you grow
there's a hundred different ways to win
this game
the only way to guarantee that you don't
win is by doing nothing about it
there is not enough content being made
in enough platforms from this group here
I'll give you an example of another
thing that some of the more advanced
people here are not thinking about I
would argue that 10 to 15 of my content
that I make I make for information but
why I'm really making it is I'm
basically asking the audience a question
and I'm reading all the comments to get
the insights
that I'm getting the consumer insights
and the pulse of the world through
putting out content just
for the reactions and the comments and
the answers
the more people here get curious and
focused and strategic about the content
they make the more the upside will be my
friends we are living in the greatest
era of marketing and business ever the
opportunities are bigger than ever
more of us can get more of a piece of
the pie than ever we have the biggest
Platforms in the world of attention
costing free this is insane not only
that if you have to do a regular job
while you trace your dream when I was
growing up there was no internet and so
you worked your job nine to seven and
when you went home you couldn't build
your dream every person here can work
their nine to five and then build their
dream on the internet at six seven eight
nine ten we are walking around Earth
everybody Brazil the US Europe we are
walking around and spending all of our
time talking about what's not working
complaining about what's not working
deciding who's in control and we're not
and yet all of us here as we sit here
today are living in the best that the
world has ever been health-wise
money-wise opportunity wise the best
you don't believe that because you read
and consume content on social media and
mainstream media that tells you it's not
but take a step back and pay very close
attention I promise you you have way
more opportunity than your grandmother
and grandfather had
promise
and
the most interesting part for me on that
is we're not taking advantage of it so
as I wrap up the actual perspective
it is time for every person in the seat
right now to become accountable
there's nobody stopping you
you may think there is but it's not true
there's not a single person on Earth
stopping you you were capable and you
have how many people here
have a cell phone
raise your hands
who here does not have a cell phone
can you put the lights on does anybody
not have a cell phone no [__] don't
be funny do you really actually okay
you're being funny
thank you not one person here does not
have a cell phone
fair enough but she's not here
this
is the remote control of the universe
every single thing that you are sitting
here on the ground or in a seat hoping
and dreaming could happen can happen
because of this
the only thing that's stopping you is
your mental perspective or your lack of
knowledge on how to do it
please no matter what you do
please get serious about LinkedIn
YouTube YouTube shorts Twitter X snap
Instagram Tick Tock please get serious
the attention of the entire world is on
these eight or nine platforms at scale
it costs zero
money to post on it this is an
opportunity that has never existed in
the history of mankind and we are all
sitting here on our hands not doing
enough
the fact that not every person in this
room raised their hand when I said do
you post on social media every day
speaks to and don't forget we're not
here for a conference talking about
movies
this is not a conference talking about
sneakers we're not here talking about
the environment this is a [__]
business conference
this is a [__] business conference
and you're [__] sitting here and not
posting on social every day [__] you
thank you
you don't have to because you don't give
a [__] Mazel Tov I'm happy
but if you are not posting on social
because your business is good enough and
you're happy please be careful
I've seen this movie over and over and
now I have gray hairs
and kids you know what happens with gray
hairs experience and you know what comes
with experience you've seen this movie
before I was at conferences like this 15
years ago when everyone was like I'm
good I have email marketing I don't need
search
I was at conferences when people said
I'm good with search I'm perfect I got
searched I don't need YouTube YouTube's
a fad Twitter's a fad Facebook's a fad
tick tock's a fad I remember for some of
you that are older remember this thing
how many people here had a Blackberry
before this phone raise your hands raise
it high
kids
keep it high one more time keep it up
kids do you know how many of these
people that raised their hands said they
would never get an iPhone because they
needed the buttons on the [__]
BlackBerry
humans are very good at saying no
no I don't want to know AI it's bad no I
don't care about Tick Tock it's for kids
Brazil as I leave this stage I ask you
for one thing
if you sit in this audience and you say
no a lot promise me one thing change
that no to maybe
Maybe
spend five hours actually downloading
and researching and trying taste it
taste it
do that you'll find yourself in a much
bigger place than you started
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]